hello everyone I'm Eddie Redmayne and
I'm here with my co-stars Katherine
Waterston and Alison sudol and Dan
Fogler from the new film fantastic
beasts and where to find the Harry
Potter films had a tremendous impact on
an entire generation we're all very
honored and excited to help JK Rowling
bring a whole new era of magic to life
it's the story of Maja's religious Newt
Scamander who arrives in New York and
accidentally unleashes his magical
beasts into the city I was hoping just a
summation in his attempts to recover his
mischievous creatures he befriends two
magical sisters and one unsuspecting
nomad that's what we call muggles here
in America together the foursome become
unlikely friends as an unpredictable
chain of events sweeps them into a race
to uncover the dark forces threatening
both the Wizarding World and the no
match
explore more magic on keno check and
join us in cinemas across Germany on
November the 17th don't panic there's
absolutely nothing to worry about